The official results of the National Electoral Council are already available and
we are going to review each one of them and how the participation of citizens by
"yes" and "no" evolves with a percentage that we have already pointed out.
But let's start with the question we have on screen,
do you agree to allow complementary support of the armed forces in the functions
of the National Police to combat organized crime by
partially reforming the constitution?
This is the question that goes directly to
the approval of the Ecuadorian people.
These are the results for the yes 66 point 81% and for the no 30 and
% This is the last cut of the National Electoral Council.
We repeat official data of the National Electoral Council,
which is equivalent to approximately 200 minutes of 40:03 1.
000 at the national level.
This percentage evolves as the minutes go by,
but they are official and already correspond to the
minutes entered at the national level.
This is the cut made by the National Electoral Council at 6:00 p.m.
and with 50 minutes they report this data.
Box b.
Do you agree to allow the extradition of Ecuadorians with the conditions,
requirements,
restrictions and impediments established in the constitution,
international instruments and law?
Amending the Constitution and amending the laws in accordance with Annex One.
So far the official cut says the following: "For the yes vote 58 point
72% of the votes and for the no vote 41 point 28% of the votes and that
also correspond to the cut made of 18 hours and 50 minutes.
Almost two hours later,
and the official start of the electoral process,
the count will be resumed immediately and will of course be shared
as long as it is also updated on the page of the National Electoral
Council with the data it has publicly provided.